welcome to this video playing the risk
junkie from Norway so let's play for
let's play simple classical chess the
classical line against the the perfect
defense which M is an old favorite of a
lovely cap off and never really
understood what white hassium probably
he doesn't have much but anyway let's
test it let's test it in practice I'm
just going to going to develop pieces to
the sender ID hope that's okay
Bishop to with you for as certainly a
move that I'd like to play and maybe
maybe right right away all right maybe I
should have played each three first now
that I think of it
okay so it looks at first quite quite
nice somehow with all these active
pieces but it's not clear that it is
doing something something can Creed
getting Bishop to b6 in the mix yeah as
usual the knight on c3 SL rather stupid
piece it just mainly looks at b5 and d5
and wonders why there's a pawn on d6
yeah this this night never wants to go
to see form but really hard to to get to
get them
it's that way to activate the night like
I just described maybe maybe I can try
to go c c1 d3 something like that
queen g5 I can play Queen g3 does it
really doesn't really help him
okay my dear now is signal Queen B 6 the
only weakness here is a five
intending c3
hmm yeah I can go to see for this was
very unnatural what I did there and the
Spanish problem okay he's retreating
this is good news let's correct the
rakia rock f rock t1 Quincy form would
have been punished I would have punished
my play quite severely okay um but it
still continues this game
32 is going to play Queen v6 probably
came
just tickling him a bit and asking what
are you playing now k if you take screen
f3 I'll get it back and part where h6
might irritate them I have this looks
like a weakness so I'm on the way c43 f5
and it's not bad on c4 wow wow this is
wow this is a positional capitulation
giving away b5 and d5 and f5 so this is
how you win in the classical pills at
some point they they weaken all their
squares now I've even have any of having
the D file okay so i don't really want
to I don't want one to exchange but
wait wait for just a moment he M
hmm
it looks like there should be some some
way to win here that Knight takes Queen
g8 or something but I don't say don't
see a win
ok this this is good as well
but I guess there was something that
even he really he really killed himself
here with with c5 and allowing this set
up on the Kings side check
we never lied resigned I wonder really
in this position isn't there like night
h6 or something no faith 97-93 as is
somewhat better even but this is of
course of course very good with Queen d3
and this idea it's almost indefensible I
guess our king of 87 keep the game going
but the real the real issues were he
played g5 and this is really bad and and
then c5 was just just unbelievable
really I mean absolute data is not a
threat and chest that can be sold can be
so strong that you need to play move
like 365 because it just it just gives
away everything I I wasn't threatening
night be sick a queen bee 60 or
something it can just play rock t7 or
whatever it gets tricky anyway because I
have this idea but after giving away
these additional squares it's just just
too much now with the default that it's
really should be over all right thanks
for watching